You didn't come to the rooftop during your lunch break It's a very pleasing story
Then I'll be waiting
No, you won't be confessed
again This time, don't
do it first  I was just talking to a woman and my face turned bright
red.Nyaaah, hey, Mob-kun.
I'm not going to surprise the onlookers who have gathered at the place I
drank, but
actually there's a group of fans who've been looking for martial arts.
seems to have been caught on camera for a moment, and
video analysis identified a few schools from the sk clothes.
So we hang around saying that the identity of our guru is already me.
You might be able to win a prize, and you were conscious of even the archives Tower set a goal properly
Next year we can't do what, why are we going to take the exam?
I was thinking of confessing to Atsubomi-chan if I won the prize, but what the heck is the
student council election?
Eh,
if next year
doesn't work out, I have no choice but to finish in the top 10 at next week's marathon.